would be easier to count the ways that
it didn't affect my life because it just
affected my life in in so many ways
Hayden Christensen is reflecting on the
many ways that Star Wars changed his
life while taking part in varieties
actors on actors series with Andor star
Diego Luna Hayden looked back on being
cast as Anakin Skywalker AKA Darth Vader
indeed hugely successful franchise
it gave me an acting career it gave me
you know Financial stability which as a
you know a creative person is something
that you know you can struggle with what
Star Wars has has really given me is is
a connection to all the people that love
these stories it's such a special thing
that you can't fully appreciate unless
you're sort of a part of something like
that but to have that sort of impact on
an audience yeah and have that sort of
carry with them and stay with them I
mean I meet people now and
and it makes me feel a little bit old
but they'll say to me you know like
Anakin was my hero when I was a kid and
now like my kid loves Anakin and it's
like this generational thing that that
kind of gets passed down and that's you
know really special Hayden also spoke
about surprising his iconic role in the
Obi-Wan Kenobi mini-series which hit
Disney plus last year oh there you are
beginning to think you weren't coming
Star Wars holds a very special place in
my heart and I enjoy getting to sort of
go back to being a fan again and just
sort of watching these stories like
everyone else but you know there's a
part of me that missed it too and so
when I got the call it was a very easy
decision and the fact that it was the
Obi-Wan show with Ewan McGregor who's a
good friend of mine and that I'd get to
work with him again and swing a
lightsaber with him again that was just
a thrilling invitation
and Hayden dished on what it's really
like filming those lightsaber scenes
which as it turns out is not as easy as
it looks
the Jedi's goal is to defend life not
take it
[Music]
it's been pretty hard and you missed
every now and then too and you'd get
like a hit on the knuckles or something
and I I'm not always left Mark but
getting to swing of lightsaber is pretty
awesome and I got to keep a couple of
them from the one from the prequels and
then I got to keep two lightsabers from
the Obi-Wan show one Darth Vader and one
Anakin because they're a little bit
different